a local family is calling on the las
vegas community for some help they say a
high-speed crash in december really
changed their entire world after months
in the hospital they're running out of
money to care for their loved one and
they're not sure where to go from here
sasha loftis joining us now live with
more sasha
brian josh bolster holds life completely
turned upside down back in december and
he's still here at umc tonight fighting
to survive now his family wants to do
everything they can to give him a
fighting chance at a full recovery
everywhere he goes everyone loves him
josh bolsterholt's family shares the
light he shines on everyone's life when
you're around him you just want to laugh
the 19 year old has a bright future
but one day in december it all changed
we looked left and there was a car
coming right at us josh and his brother
jacob were leaving work when they say a
car which crash reports listed as
traveling over 100 miles per hour hit
them josh was thrown from the car here
on raiders way in henderson hi josh he
was in a coma for two months now he
needs physical and occupational therapy
we don't have the means we don't have
the money josh's mom joelle says
medicaid won't cover it and they're
running out of options so she's calling
on the community for help i need this
community to like stand up and fight for
him
and please help him and try to get him
in a skilled facility they also say
they're here sharing this pain to
encourage others to slow down it's a
thrill but really take a second think
before you
you go you push that pedal because
you never know and think of josh
all the time he's lost
and everything his family is going
through
to get him back he's a good boy and he
deserves a fighting chance
now he would like to help josh and his
family we do have a link on our website
with more information that's 8 news now
dot com reporting live tonight sasha
loftis live local now